hi I'm poppy here at BuzzFeed and I'm
going to talk about my first times first
time you realized you were famous well I
just realized now I didn't think I was
famous before but I like famous people
first pet mmm my first pet is PI here's
my cat I'm not sure if he's my pet or
I'm his pet he is less sphynx cat and he
tells me what to do first celebrity
crush maybe that would be dead to Kali
he's back now but still David Bell first
crazy rumor you heard about yourself it
was that I was a boy but now I'm not
sure maybe I'm a boy or maybe I'm a girl
first big purchase as a celebrity I
probably say Charlotte the mannequin
sometimes I regret that purchase but
that was my first one first Instagram
post me eating cotton candy and a video
on YouTube and then I put it first
memory probably dressing up as a firefly
for Halloween a small pop again first
thing you do when you wake up I usually
check Instagram and then I make myself a
cup of tea to enjoy with my very best
friend
first job
this first hmm I don't have a home so I
don't think I can answer that one
first dream you I have dreams all the
time my first dream was probably to
become a dancer but then I became a
singer and that's also a dream for mine
and I get to do it every day so I'm
living it and that was my first with my
sweet
[Music]
[Music]